what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime All Pro and today I will be
talking about what is maybe my favorite
twist in the entire black holders story
so far
after first torturing us with the
arrogance and corruption of the nobles
and their so-called justice system
tabata just changed the game and created
one of the most hype plot points in the
entire series in my opinion I am
extremely excited to break it all down
for you right here in this video so
let's get into it if you enjoyed the
black clover content on this channel and
you'd like to see more you can let me
know by leaving a like and if you happen
to be new to anime uproar and you don't
want to miss any future uploads please
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell heads up there will be
manga spoilers in this video we're
dealing with the latest developments in
the black clover story with that said
proceed with caution
you have been warned chapter 218 starts
off with everyone around the clover
kingdom including Rebecca Anne Teresa in
the common realm and father or she and
sister lily and the orphans in the
forsaken realm reading in the newspaper
that hasta is a traitor and a criminal
who uses forbidden devil magic this
means that the propaganda campaign
designed to vilify hasta was already in
full swing even before his so-called
trial started and the people of the
clover Kingdom are already being
manipulated into hating hasta and seeing
him as a threat that needs to be
eliminated
damnatio goal is to get rid of asta but
he doesn't want the people of the
kingdom to complain about him executing
someone who just helped save the whole
kingdom so by making us to look evil in
the media
damnatio will avoid all public criticism
for his actions and for his sham of a
trial in the photo that came with the
newspaper hasta is portrayed as a
demonic and scary-looking creature but
the funny thing is that to the orphans
in Haga village he just looks cool and
they can't believe that that's actually
supposed to be hasta the news of
austin's alleged treason has even gotten
to the former villains of the kingdom
including Gelder Pozzo rev G Sally
Radice and maltose who are doing
community service in order to atone for
their sins meanwhile our boy Jack the
Ripper is there to keep the criminals in
line
and he threatens to slice them up if
they don't pipe down and get back to
work
I'm actually interested to see what is
going to happen with all these former
villains are they going to try to
rehabilitate them all and are they going
to succeed or will some of these guys
return to a life of crime and pose more
threats to our heroes in the future
personally I don't think that these guys
are going to be major villains ever
again they might make for interesting
rival characters kind of like speedo
sounds sonic in one punch man but I
don't see any of these guys posing a
major threat in the future I have to say
that I do really like Sally as a
character so I hope they keep her around
in some capacity even if it's just as a
friendly rival or nerdy comic relief
according to mimosa who is discussing
the situation with Klaus damnatio has
even judged his own father in the past
so it would not be surprising if he
decided to condemn Austin and blame him
for everything that happened even though
we all know that Austin was not
responsible for the war in fact he
played a major role in saving the
kingdom I found that brief statement
that we most amazed about the nation's
father quite interesting who was his
father and what did his father do for
them natio to judge and condemn him I
have a feeling that this will come up
again in the near future Klaus says to
mimosa that if they decided to help us
that they would have to stand against
the entire justice system of the clover
Kingdom basically even though they know
Austin didn't do anything wrong
if they try to support him or help him
in any way they could all be treated as
criminals and even their families could
be punished for it this is more proof
that damnatio is just using the full
force of the clover kingdoms justice
system for his own personal benefit he
will do whatever it takes to get his own
way and he doesn't care in the least
about who he has to hurt to do it back
inside the magic congress building the
nobles and damnatio are outraged when
they see Asta's demon form also known as
the black asked the form they are going
on about how the legends were true and
asked his appearance matches what they
heard about devils and their horns and
dark aura and black wings etc of course
we know that hasta entered this form not
because he wants to attack anyone but
because he was forced to do it in order
to save marie damnatio deliberately
provoked him into showing his power and
this tells me that the natio actually
knows
more about hasta that we might have
thought at first even though we haven't
seen them natio before this arc he has
clearly been keeping an eye on hasta and
he knew how to get hasta to do exactly
what he wanted damnatio used Marie
because he knew that hasta was the type
of person who would do anything to
protect someone innocent and he also
knew that when hasta uses his powers his
appearance changes in a way that makes
him look demonic damnatio wanted all the
nobles inside the magic congress to see
hasta looking like a dangerous demon so
he made sure that this is exactly what
happened by threatening to hurt Marie
hasta again tries to rationally explain
what his form really is he explains that
it is just a temporary powerup that he
can control and that it isn't going to
hurt or attack anyone however and
unsurprisingly the nobles scream about
how they could never trust the possessed
the devil child and they continue to
call him a low-class commoner filth who
has been soiled by the devil's power the
nobles call frost has immediate
execution before he can cause more harm
to the clover kingdom and them natio
calmly tells us that to just accept his
fate
damnatio is such an evil bastard that I
can't even believe it he tells us so
that even if he escapes the magic
Congress he will still be a wanted man
they would pursue him all over the
kingdom and he would have nowhere to
hide and if that wasn't enough damnatio
implies that if oscar runs the orphanage
where he grew up and everyone who still
lives there will suffer the consequences
this guy is truly a top-tier scumbag it
would be one thing if them natio truly
believed that hasta is evil and a threat
to the kingdom and even though we all
know that this would be a false belief I
could understand them natio not trusting
someone he doesn't know and someone who
has a strange demonic power that he
doesn't understand but clearly damnatio
already knows that hasta is a good and
noble person and the natio is using that
very fact against him damnatio is
willing to hurt innocent people that
hasta cares about just to manipulate
asta into complying with his demands
which to me says that the natio is fully
aware that hasta is not a bad guy if
asta was a bad guy why would he care
about the fact that the natio threatened
to hurt innocent people he cares because
he's a good guy and he wants to protect
them damnatio does not care in the least
about the truth and justice so calling
him the scales of justice or anything
even remotely related to justice is an
absolute joke
damnatio is the very definition of
injustice and as damnatio tells austin
that he has nowhere to run and that no
one is going to help him because he just
brings misfortune upon everyone around
him a loud blast interrupts the
proceedings and a section of the magic
congress's wall collapses the nobles
damnatio and hasta are stunned to see
Yami and the Black Bulls make their
grand entrance into the magic Congress
building our boy Yami says that he was
told that the trial was going to be the
day after tomorrow
meaning that he was deliberately given
the wrong information so that he
couldn't interfere this is just further
proof that this so-called trial was
always a premeditated plot by damnatio
and there was never any intention of
giving hasta a fair hearing Yami
Inglorious Yami fashion says that he
doesn't give a damn whether hasta is
evil or a devil or whatever else because
Yami acknowledged him as a man among men
and as his precious comrade the black
Bulls refused to let hasta be railroaded
like this and they all voiced their
devotion to hasta as their friend and
comrade in arms and of course Noel in
her classic assume that F fashion calls
Austin idiot but she says that even she
acknowledges that someone like him is
needed by the kingdom although it's not
like she needs him or anything
Baca man noel is such a stereotypical
sundari but i can't help but love her
dynamic with hasta as cliche as it is
the black Bulls complete with their
black bull base in its epic mecha form
declared that they're going to be taking
a stop back damnatio starts talking
about how the magic congress has the
legal authority in the entire kingdom
and how dare the black bulls interfere
with the proceedings of the justice
system in this way bla bla bla then the
issue even threatens the army and says
that if he tries to defend the criminal
who was the cause of the entire war then
the position of the black bulls will be
severely jeopardized
but Yami merely states that the black
bulls are already considered the worst
of the worst
and he says that both hasta and Sacre
are their members and no one can lay a
hand on them Yami proclaims that the
black bulls don't give a damn about
treason or the Congress and if anyone
tries to mess with their friends the
black bulls are coming after them period
and that's how the chapter ends with the
black bulls advancing on them natio and
the scumbag Nobles determined to rescue
Austin Sacre from this profoundly unfair
and unjust charade of a trial I have to
say that I was feeling extremely
frustrated at the beginning of this
chapter and I was getting so sick of the
nobles and their natio and their BS with
that said I was so pleasantly surprised
and hyped to see the black Bulls storm
in like this and show Austin Sacre that
they are not alone
that their comrades will defend them no
matter what and seriously at this point
Yami has to be one of the greatest
mentor characters in all of anime and
manga my personal favorite is still
coming out from Gurren Lagann but Yami
is an absolute legend and I freaking
love this glorious Japanese badass but
in terms of what the black Bulls just
did make no mistake about it this is
going to get complicated we all know
that laws are important for order and
the proper functioning of society and we
live in a society but what was going on
inside the magic Congress was not lawful
or just it was the embodiment of
corruption manipulation and mistreatment
when a system is so blatantly unjust and
when the so-called authorities are
willing to attack innocent children like
Murray just to prove a point then
fighting back against this system is the
only option with that said this could be
the beginning of a serious civil
conflict maybe even a civil war inside
the clover kingdom the black bulls just
directly defied the entire ruling system
they officially became criminals and
outlaws by breaking into the magic
Congress and fighting back against them
natio and the nobles after this the
entire ruling class of the clover
kingdom with maybe a few exceptions will
be out to destroy the black bulls and
the conflict is sure to be a massive one
at this point I think that something
will seriously have to change in the
ruling structure of the clover kingdom
we can't keep having these arrogant
ignorant and completely corrupt in
competent Nobles ruling the kingdom and
abusing everyone in sight by the time
that this civil conflict ends I predict
that the ruling system will have to
change in some meaningful way maybe
someone who is a royal but also a good
and honorable person like Fugo leon is
going to become the next wizard king and
take all the power away from augustus
kira clover at this point these arrogant
bastards can't lose their power soon
enough if you ask me but let me know
what you guys think are we about to see
a major civil war inside the clover
kingdom and if so how do you think that
this will all end will the ruling
structure of the kingdom finally change
and by the way how freaking awesome is
Yami and how amazing are the black bulls
as a whole man I love these guys one of
the best squads in anime period I know
I'm going a bit nuts here I am extremely
excited and hyped after this chapter but
don't forget to give me your thoughts
down in the comments below I always
enjoy hearing from you if you enjoyed
this video and you want to see more
black lore videos on this channel please
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar please don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell if you don't make sure
to hit the bell and indicate that you
want to see all notifications many of
our videos will probably slip under the
cracks and you won't be notified
unfortunately that is just how YouTube
works so you really have to hit that
Bell feel free to follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at anime uproar for all
the latest black clover news and updates
I want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime upper patrons for supporting
our work and making our videos possible
a special thank you to all of our pro
hero to your patrons including the one
and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson King zelgius and on he'll
cruise on epic thank you to all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
above all other clans including baby ray
ace
Ingrid ah Aloha Adam Maddy Mac
makoto-kun and keelon and finally at the
pinnacle of interdimensional greatness
at ear reserved only for legends a
massive thank you to regan Harrison and
Lord naksan or disciples of Lord we go
himself if you enjoy our videos and you
think they provide value for you
consider
supporting us on patreon link in the
description even a single dollar will
give you access to our exclusive patron
only discord and your name will appear
in our videos along with these amazing
people as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see us
bass cowboys
[Music]